thank you maurice yes i'm here with uh
wesley so after a peaceful yet quite
tense
uh affair wesley take us through the
game and uh how do you feel right now
you're the leader but who knows for how
long no i'm not the leader i'm the
co-leader oh
no i'm plus one and grief chuck and shaq
are plus two
ah yeah they're plus two okay
okay and shaq are both playing and but
anyway first it's uh i'm glad to be here
again in the studio
so okay today was
a very forcing game
i mean i i think we kind of both
prepared all the way until
move 18 or something so after
knight c3 bishop b4 taymor always plays
bishop g5 he also plays queen a4
but then i wasn't really sure what he
would play he could also play cd5 i mean
i'm not sure how ambitious he will be
today
so after bishop g5 takes e4 h6 i started
this line a few days ago and this is
also the line where fabiano beat levon
iranian the candidates 2018
very famous but we need to so basically
all these
moves are forced for black and it's very
dangerous for black because
black has a bishop player but the pawn
e5 is very strong
and one wrong move uh could
easily kill black but also one move one
removed by white could
could easily kill white yeah or at least
have a very uh
strategical position because of the
bishop here yeah but basically like
black is playing only moves from move 12
to like mob 16
and yeah bishop d7 do you think he was
aware of the
theory here yeah i think so i'm spending
a lot of time no i think
he he definitely knew the theory because
i played this once in 2018
against nihal sarin uh
but i mean the engines are not giving
anything
critical for white i mean white doesn't
have any killing though
uh for example i prepared here rook
also request e1 bishop before attacks
the rope
and let's say white can play knight h5
and then bishop c6 for example in this
position black has to
take this knight because otherwise you
take the
rook and i type six if you have killing
the engine
doesn't show it at first but this is
just
winning four four white uh by fourth
three takes up six and then if oh wow if
you're still saying that black is doing
quite well
yeah and then if you continue a bit
further now it changes yeah
yeah now and now if you go king to h8
probably some rope h4
yeah or or rook g6 queen fit2 winning by
fourth
that's very nice but yeah basically this
line is very risky for black but the
same time hasn't been refuted yet and
fabiana played it before
basically yeah bishop d7 they're also
rook v8 but i think bishop d7 with the
idea of bishop c6 for important for
example if you make
one bad ordinary move like knight c6
your position becomes very difficult
right away
because the bishops needed on c6
now i prefer knight f6 there have been
some games knight f16 g7
takes but the king just takes the pawn
then goes back to g7
and black is very close to the quality i
think they more prepared bishop d3
and which looks dangerous uh
i mean black can probably play knight v6
but it looks very risky
i can also play bishop a4 first just to
provoke b3 but i'm not sure it does
anything
but after bishop c6 takes knight d7
against on the move
so basically black is just in time to
defend the king's side with knight takes
e5
were you still within your theoretical
knowledge at this point
i think bishop d3 was a novelty by
taymor but i might have seen it as he
was thinking for a very long time he was
spending a lot of time at this point
yeah i think players do that just to get
into the rhythm just
to remember also you have 90 minutes
so just to get yourself warmed up to the
game
i i think uh even if you think for 20
minutes it could still be in your
preparation like alexander christian
the other day later e1 maybe
black can also play rook 8 to
keep playing uh and probably black is
completely fine
but one thing to avoid here though is
bishop b4 which looks tempting it
attacks the rook
but in fact it's knight x26 and that's
just completely losing at this point
yeah and then just a game checkmate is
coming yes i think knight takes c5 was
the
safest by far because now he has to take
already
spawn down and i guess if
this end game is obviously called
bishops maybe white can push very little
bit
but i thought king f1 maybe not king f1
i thought he could try some
rook c1 rook fd8
and then uh rook
h3 this seems to be quite close to uh
equality at this point yeah it should be
there i mean
and then there's four buttons absolutely
absolutely opposite color bishops wesley
you are
a little bit behind the leaders what are
you going to do in the last few rounds
to catch up
yeah try to win the title yeah obviously
it'll be nice to win the game uh but the
thing is when opponents are very strong
you never know when a win
happens or when an accident happens
but i'll be yesterday i tried against i
think i had some chances around move 36
also around move 32 if i played rpd 1795
with some chances but uh
well it'll be very nice to win a game
but we'll see what happens quite
difficult to get advantage in
in the opening and also if shaq
wins today against fabiano then probably
the title pretty much
goes to him because he's gonna have
white and he's gonna have plus three
it's definitely looking good for uh shaq
wesley thank you very much for joining
us
and uh we're looking forward to see you
in the next few days thank you yeah
i'll try to give my best awesome thank
you thank you